سجن غذائي تصدره السعوديه الى الخارج قبل
سنوات قليله دشنت او دشنت علامه تمر
السعوديه احدى مبادرات المركز الوطني
للنخيل والتمور التي تعنى برفع جوده
الانتاج في قطاع النخيل والتمور الزمناه
في الاحمر يعرفنا اكثر على علامه التمور
السعوديه
السعوديه اكبر مصدر للتمور حول العالم هذه
الحقيقه مشاهدينا جاءت بمساهمه علامه تمور
السعوديه التي ادت لزياده قيمه صادرات
المملكه من التمور بنسبه 36% من اجمالي
قيمه الصادرات علامه التمور السعوديه
بمثابه وسم يقيم سلمه المنتج وجودته وفق
معايره عالميه في الممارسات الزراعيه
والصناعيه والضمان سلسله الامداد ضمن ثلاث
تصنيفات الاول تصنيف ممتاز للحبه الكبيره
والتصنيف اول لحبه التمر المتوسطه واخيرا
تصنيف ثاني للحبه الصغيره نسبه امتثال
المزارع والشركات المختصه بانتاج التمور
لهذا التقييم تجاوزت عتبه الاربعين في
المئه
مئه وسبعه وخمسون مصنعا للتمور تتواجد في
السعوديه تغطي نحو ثلاثه ملايين نخله
تستهدفها علامه التمور المصانع الحاصله
على علامه تمور السعوديه تحظى بعدد من
المزايا منها اولويه مشاركه في المعارض
المحليه والدوليه الخاصه بالتمور فضلا عن
تسهيلات اخرى لزياده فرص التسويق والتصدير
على سبيل المثال يتم انهاء مخلصتهم
الجمركيه لتصدير واصدار الشهاده النباتيه
لهم باقل من ساعه بدلا من اربعه ايام عمل
كما في السابق
وتحظى مشاهدينا مزارع التمور بخصم على
الخدمات يصل ل 10% نظيره انضمامها لبرنامج
الولاء زارع
المستهلك هو المستفيد الاول والشريك
لانجاح هذا المشروع الوطني وله دور بالحد
من رواجر منتجات الغير مطابقه من خلاله
تفحصه الباركود المطبوع على صناديق التمر
المباعه في الاسواق والمزادات والمعارض
بهذه الطريقه يعرف المستهلك مصدر التمور
وموثقيه الشراء من خلال قراءه الباركود
الموجود على المنتجات
نا من الرياض مدير علامه التمور السعوديه
ناصر حياك الله حياك الله استاذ خالد شكرا
لكم شكرا لفريق العمل التي تقدمه هذه
العلامه علامه التمور
للجهات او الفئات المستهدفه من المزارعين
والمصانع وغيرها همم علامه مصر السعوديه
تقدم القيمه المضافه في ادت مسارات لل
سواء للمساء للمزارع ولا المصانع ولا
الشركات التسويقيه الحاصله عليها همم على
سبيل المثال في مسار التصدير همم العلامه
سهله اجراءات همم اصدار شهاده الصحه
النباتيه من منافذ بشكل مباشر في مده تقل
الساعه واحده بدلا على اجراء الاعتياطي
كان خلال اربع ايام عمل همم ايضا اعتمدت
الاعلام تمارس السعوديه من قبل همم
الجمارك في جمارك جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
متطلب رئيسي للتصدير الى دوله جمهوريه
الصين كما اعت اعلام التمر السعوديه مراكز
التبخير التي تصدر شهادات همم التبخير الى
دول استراليا والهند بحيث انك تتم عمليه
التبخير المنتجات للقضاء على اصابات
الحشريه عن طريق المصانع المنتسبه لعلامه
التمر السعوديه همم في مسار التسويق
اولويه المشاركه في المعارض والمؤتمرات
التي يعمل عليها الملك سلمان بحيث انه
نبرز المنتجات اللي عليها علامه تمر
السعوديه اللي هي تعتبر هويه للتمور كذلك
في المنصات الكترونيه الان لدى المركزت
عده منصات الكترونيه
السعوديه للاعمال المنصه تمر السعوديه
للتجزئه تعرض فيها بشكل حصري المنتجات
الحاصله على علامه نور السعوديه وكذلك في
همم
المسار الخاص بالمزارعين تم انشاء منصه
خاصه بسوق المزارعين من وسط المزاد
الكتروني على همم على مدى طوال الموسم همم
المعتمده والحاصل على العلامه بح انها
تعرف فيها منتجاتها طوال فتره الموسم همم
في مسار الدعم في مسار الدعم المزارعين
اطلاقنا برنامج ولاء خاص بالمزارع النخيل
يقدم لهم خصومات على المدخلات الزراعيه
كذلك خدمات ما با- خدمات ما بعد الحصوات
مثل عمليات التعبئه والتخزين والتغريفه
التي تهم المزارع في براسم منتجاته لزياده
القيمه السوقيه كذلك في الخدمات العامه
على سبيل المثال التاجير السيارات التمويل
التاجيريا يحصل على مزايا من خلال شركانه
في القطاع الخاص همم في مسار همم
بس خليني اسالك عن عدد المزارع على
المصانع
واللي حصلت حتى الان على على علامه التمور
كمان علامه
بالنسبه للمزارع حصلت تقريبا 6% من النخيل
المملكه على علامه السعوديه تمثل عدد
المزارع تقريبا
4,700 مزرعه من 123,000 زراعيه في ما يخص
مصانع التمور حاصله عليها 57 مصنع مثل
التربين في المئه تقريبا اجمالي مصانع
التمور في المملكه
بعد ذلك هل يمكنكم من خلال هذه العلامه
الان يعني
تقضوا على التلاعب المتعلق بتحديد الفاخر
من هذه التمور تمور فاخره او غيرها بعض
مثلا يتلاعب بهذه المساله فبالتالي انتم
كيف بتتاكدوا من القضيه هذه العلامه احد
اهدافها توحيد تصنيف التمر في المملكه
بحيث نعمل على المواصفات القياسيه
استرشاديه للتمور بحيث ان نحدد فئه المنتج
من خلال هل سواء هو فاخره او تمور ممتازه
او تمور قيا او الدرجه التصنيعيه استخدام
في الصناعه ال- ال- المواصفه السعوديه همم
هدفها اللي هو تسهيل اول التسهيل التجاره
همم الدوليه والمحليه بين التجار وبين
المزارعين ثاني حاجه ثاني هدف اللي هو همم
توعيه همم او نقول ضمان حصول المستهلك على
المنتج مول بحيث ان يضمن الدرجه المكتوبه
على عبوه المنتج بالتوفيق شكرا جزيلا لك
مدير علامه التمور السعوديه